There's nothing like having a whole plate
of stink beans
right before you get on the airplane.
Oh yah.
Chai mai krub Ying?
Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com.
Today is the day, or actually a little bit
later tonight, my wife Ying and I will be
starting our round the world trip for food
with Star Alliance.
And I have been so excited the last couple
days that last night I could barely even sleep
because I could not control my excitement
to start this trip.
I have some packing to do, actually I think
I might just show you a little bit of my packing,
I want to show you some of the gear that I'm
taking with me on this trip.
Then I'm going to have a quick dinner, then
we're going to jump in a taxi and we are on
our way to the airport.
I am very grateful to have an amazing wife
who packs all of my clothes.
Oh there she is.
But it is up to me to pack all of the electronics.
I'm going to do this kind of quick and snappy.
I have three external hard drives each of
them are two terabytes each.
These two I'll be backing up everything twice,
all of the content, all of the videos.
These are battery chargers.
I got four extra batteries.
Two cameras.
This is an extra lens.
This is the main camera that I'll be using.
I have an extra Rode video mic, this has a
terrible name, but it's really called a dead kitten,
which is to put over a microphone
to cancel out the wind.
It's a wind breaker.
A flashlight, some wires, some cleaning equipment,
my phone.
Got my main computer here which I'll be editing
everything with, the cables, a mouse, you've
got to have a mouse when you're video editing.
Some waterproof bags, some bags.
These are the only tripods that I'll be using,
they are easy to handle and they are very
transportable, very easy.
These are highly important, which are, and
I would recommend it for anyone who is traveling.
These are all purpose plugs for anywhere you
are in the world, there's nothing better than
arriving somewhere and you have no idea what
the plug is and not having to worry about
it, but you can just use this thing.
It's all purpose.
And then a, this is an extra battery.
And one more thing that I always travel with
is a power strip.
There are, it's amazing how all the hotels
around the world, they all seem to have just
one or two plugs, and when you have to plug
in five different things or ten different
things at once, this is absolutely key.
Apart from, let me see if I can show you over
here.
Oh here's Ying's makeup mirror, oh and there's
Ying.
This is our second camera, so we'll be taking
two cameras with us, and yah that's all of
the gear that we'll be taking with us on this
trip to film this entire vlogging series and
making videos.
Ying and I are going to be traveling for about
a month and a half outside of Thailand, so
there was no way I was going to leave Southeast
Asia with out a plate of stink beans.
Which is one of my all time favorite things
in the entire world.
My mother in law has just cooked a typical
meal that I eat at home all the time.
We are going to definitely have dinner on
the airplane tonight as well.
They just never get old.
Oh they are so good.
So refreshing and with such a unique taste
and texture and crispness to them.
Follow that with some of the tom yum broth
and a shallot.
Mmm.
Oh.
It's nice and sour, it's a little bit salty
and you can just taste all of that lemongrass
and the chilies in there and the garlic.
Let me scoot aside this pile of goodies and,
fish out one of the fish.
And then you can just kind of, what I like
to do is just put my spoon on the end of the
tail here, and just kind of slide my spoon
down, and you can get pretty much the entire
fillet of mackerel.
Ohh that's hot.
Off like that though.
Buttery piece of mackerel.
Ok perfect.
I just love mackerel, it's such a wonderful
flavorful fish.
It's a little bit buttery and creamy and I
especially love it in tom yum because it's
it takes on the flavor of the lemongrass and
the lime juice and the fish sauce.
But I could just not pass up the opportunity
to eat a final home cooked meal at home before
going on this trip.
Fufu, fufu bye bye.
Bye bye.
Doesn't he look like a sheep Ying?
Is that a real dog or is that a sheep?
Man mee ma kwa, mun bear.
Fufu sia jai.
Fufu sia jai no?
Ying are you going to miss Fufu?
Ohhhh.
Ok bye!
We have about two and a half or two hours
and forty five minutes until our flight leaves,
hopefully the traffic won't be too bad.
The airport seems to be pretty quiet at this
time now.
It is about seven pm.
Kob kun krub.
Check in then customs and immigration and
security was a breeze tonight.
Namaste.
The reason that getting through customs and
immigration and checking in to our flight
was so easy is because that we are flying
on business class, and actually we're not
just flying on business class for this flight,
but for this entire round the world trip with
Star Alliance, so Ying and I are both not
only thrilled about the trip about the world
for food, but also about flying this entire
trip.
I can sleep here.
Ying have you ever had this much leg space
on an airplane?
Thank you very much.
We are about to take off.
Thank you.
It is time now for pre-dinner snacks.
I'll start with the roasted almonds.
One of the most important things to know about
eating in India is that there's veg and there's
non-veg, and veg of course means vegetarian,
but non-veg usually means any kind of meat,
or any kind of meat protein.
So I got non-veg.
There's a little bit of turbulence right now
so it's kind of shaky probably the camera
is shaking a little bit.
But this sells really really good.
I got the prawns curry, and I was expecting
some little prawns but these are huge prawns
and you can really smell.
Oh yah, that's exactly what I smell right
there, the spice, that's cardamom.
I got to go in for a roti right now or a chapati,
I think this is a chapati actually.
Oh this smells so good.
I was just going to grab some sauce but I
may as well go in for a whole prawn.
Mmmmmm.
That's pretty good.
I was so excited to start digging in to the
prawns curry that I forgot to even unravel
my napkin.
I should probably put this onto my lap.
It's actually pretty wonderful.
The curry is not even oily at all, you can
just taste all of that spice, the cardamom
in there, maybe some cumin and then yah it's
really not oily or too buttery at all.
Oh I think it's daal.
I think this is daal makhani, which is the
black lentils.
I just spilled all over my chin.
Mmmm.
That's wonderful.
You can taste the cumin in there and then
that is kind of buttery.
Welcome to Chhatrapati Shivaji International
Airport Mumbai.
The local time is thirty minutes past eleven
in the evening, and the temperature is twenty
seven degrees celcius.
Thank you.
Yes!
Oh, welcome to Mumbai.
That was a great flight, and I'm happy to
be in India.
Ok bye bye.
Bye, nice to meet you.
As soon as you pass through customs then there
is a prepaid taxi stand and so you can prepay
your taxi and then you choose either AC or
non AC and we are on our way to an area called
Colaba which is kind of the south part of
Mumbai.
Thank you, thank you.
It's about two am, we just checked into our
hotel which is called the Gordon House Hotel
right in the Colaba area in Mumbai.
We're going to be staying here for four nights
and we'll be in Mumbai for a total of four
about four full days which is not as long
as I would like, but we're going to be trying
to cram in as much food and sightseeing as
possible during our time here.
So stay tuned for this whole series, many
delicious food vlogs coming up I'm anticipating
and this is going to be a lot of fun.
Thank you all for watching.
Please remember to give this video a thumbs
up and also make sure you subscribe if you're
not already subscribed so you don't miss the
next video, and yah, I will see you tomorrow
is going to be our first real day in Mumbai.
And I am already loving how much leg space
there is on this seat.
What do I have on my sock?
Is that like a little, it looks like a fish
scale.
Ani arai krub?
Light.
Oh that's a light.
I thought that was a, I thought this was a
microphone.